So tell us why cancer, I mean, you start off as a chiropractor and then here you are,
you know, working with cancer patients and a few Lyme patients as well. So what happened there?
Well, it was just, it was an experience. So I graduated as a chiropractor but really practiced as
a functional medicine practitioner before that term existed, taking care of people with thyroid
issues and hormonal problems and had adrenal function and things. I always studied about
rife technology. So rife is a light sequencing generator and for some reason I was enthralled
with that technology and he even had it and my machine picked out that I wanted to buy at some time
but all I do about it was it was for cancer. So I wasn't seeing cancer patients at the time
and then in the late 1990s one of my patients came in and she was diagnosed with breast cancer
and both breasts and was given three months to live and did not want to do chemo irradiation. So
she literally said, if you can't help me, I'd rather die and that's what I do. I should buy a rife
machine and give this thing a shot. Well, she lived another 13 years and died of a heart attack.
So it was in that process that God really opened the door and pushed me through
and really revealed to me what I was supposed to be doing. So I loved chiropractic, I loved
taking care of people but I do there was just something missing that I was supposed to do.
A matter of fact, I graduated in 1986 and just felt that missing something for a number of years
so I ended up selling my practice and my wife and at that time, four children. But in the full-time
missionary work we worked on the Mexico and a mission in final school orphanage and God closed the door
on that, put me back in practice. I just didn't know what it was to do but I was supposed to be doing
until shark came along and that's really launched my new phone practice in taking care of people with
kids.